geil und solche leute solche aktionen
finde ich irgendwie symbolisieren oh
mein gott hat schon der baum tötet mich
alter da kommt einfach ein behinderter
zombie an meine fresse
durch meine lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge christmas kraft und zwar alleine
heute und den werten herrn komma die und
ich bin hier halb tot ich habe nur noch
ein halbes herz auf jeden fall richtig
wochen erst mal was zu essen haben wir
überhaupt immer zu fressen warten
weitere moment gar nicht sein also ich
nichts zu fressen aber 26 eisen alter
waren es nacht weil die sonne geht auf
ok dann gehe ich jetzt ein bisschen
leute klatschen wenn ich im runterfallen
direktor auch gut so meine lieben
freunde warum ist der kommen nicht aber
warum redet ein bisschen leiser es ist
nämlich gerade zehn uhr abends an einem
sonntag und der gong pendler die schon
nein keine ahnung wurde es jedenfalls
wollte jetzt eben allein eine folge
aufnehmen ich hab ja schon im kontakt
gestern gesagt dass das ganze hier so
ein bisschen aus dem ruder gerät als
helfer rudergerät also es ist halt alles
mehr oder weniger hof geplant mit der
zeit her
wenn ich jetzt auch gerade mitten in der
klausurphase stecke und alles mögliche
routen sind schafe nur dass ein skelett
wenn ich mich einmal trifft nicht immer
nicht warum ist überhaupt ein skelett
mein gott eigentlich darf dass da gar
nicht stehen
na gut wir hatten dass uns das
eigentlich komplett anders moment
komplett anders vorgestellt dieses ganze
projekt nicht so grundsätzlich form vom
aufbau her und von den themen her und
das macht es ja auch mega viel spaß aber
das den halt noch damit mit dabei ist
und dass wir das uns dann zu dritt of
time mit dem hochladen weil das wäre für
mich genau perfekte tage gewesen wo ich
dann halt mal keine klausuren schreiben
davor oder danach nach den aufnahmen et
cetera
und hier sind nur schafe dass ein
bisschen ärgerlich aber es ist halt
alles jetzt so mehr oder weniger
gekommen dass
das ganze halt genau dann liegt bei
neuaufnahmen werde ich genau nächsten
tag der klausur schreiben habe ich
dementsprechend an die zeit mit kommen
zusammen aufzunehmen sondern muss dann
immer mehr oder weniger jetzt alleine
auf eine weise kommen musste auch schon
mal eine aufnahme zwei volle hat er
schon alleine aufgenommen und wir wollen
das ganze jetzt halt mal so ein bisschen
versuchen durchzuziehen also ich nehme
jetzt heute eine folge auf für heute
montag
wenn ihr die folge gerade sehen habe ich
jetzt die folge für neun aufgenommen und
jetzt heute am 9
am abend wollten com und ich richtig
richtig viel aufnehmen also dann locker
5 6 folgen dass wir erstmal was haben
das dann erst mal abwechselnd sachen
kommen und damit das ganze projekt dann
auch machen sinn hat es das ganze nicht
irgendwie dann kommen wir zwei folgen
kommt mal wieder keine folge sondern das
ganze dann ein bisschen bestehen bleibt
auf aktueller basis und das versuchen
wir dann ein bisschen einzuhalten ob wir
das schafft eine andere sache haben wir
versucht uns auf jeden fall und ich
denke wir schaffen es dann
es liegt auch hauptsächlich eigentlich
an mir gome hat immer termine und dann
sag ich ja lassen und dann sagt er ja
und da sage ich spontan an mba heißt ich
kann doch nicht weil ich dann wieder
noch nicht zu hause bin und so das sind
das ergibt sich bei mir alle spontan
deswegen wenn danny wer mit mir
aufnehmen will muss also das von spontan
sein schreibt nicht in der kommentare
ich bin total spontan mit mir auf aber
wenn ich fänd ich finde leute die ihn
spontan sind cool und ich bin selber so
einer
nein also man muss selbst wissen ob man
sein leben hat plant und ich kann mein
leben nicht planen ich bin einfach eine
person
ich respektiere die leute die ihr leben
dieser zeiten festlegen alles nicht auch
das ist jetzt nicht aufgezogen das ist
auf keinen fall auf gott bezogen
ich hatte jetzt irgendwie denkt wenn ich
jetzt einmal runter komme bin ich tot
sondern ganz einfach ich respektiere
leute immens die ihr leben megamäßig gut
planen können von angst dass gleich
nacht wird und ich finde ich einfach
keine tierchen und so mein gott ich habe
gerade gehört da ist ne kuh ja
fleisch so dann gehe ich gleich wieder
nach hause und packt das index oder
technik kommt irgendwie herunter kommen
können nicht irgendwie äpfel runter
kommen da sie nur setzlinge auch wer
richtig geil wenn man äpfel so im ofen
backen können berater für höhe zu
weihnachten das werde ich die cool
übrigens zu weihnachten wird auch noch
mal ein special kommen am 24
das ist nicht genau einen dienstag und
da kommt ja auch immer ein sex-video
jetzt jeden dienstag also morgen halt
auch wieder und am 24
werde ich da 10 christmas facts
vorstellen wollt ihr sowas dass ich so
etwas mache also 10 10 facts allgemein
oder oder sagte er so ein camper konnte
also da es mir eure meinung auf jeden
fall wie immer wichtig mich jetzt
einfach hier runter ich habe nämlich so
angst dass ich irgendwo runterspringen
damit okay ist augenfällig
ob man das ist so ärgerlich dass ich ab
pilze und wir haben zuhause suppen
schalen deswegen auf jetzt mal wieder
nach hause und werde mir dann
wahrscheinlich nicht suppe kochen oder
irgendwie sowas und ich hoffe einfach
dass ich schaffe noch vor
sonnenuntergang wie nach hause zu kommen
aber ich denke das müsste wirklich
machbar sein soll nämlich noch ein
bisschen kohle und eisen mit einer nie
schaden ich habe ihn schon früh preisen
auch ganz gut
und dann würde ich sagen können wir
eigentlich schon also wir hoffen jetzt
dass es ab jetzt wieder vernünftig läuft
dass die nächste folge am morgen
dementsprechend bei gomez und die
übernächste dann wieder bei mir ich
hoffe dass wir so einrichten können
entschuldigung für die etwas komische
abfolge bisher tut uns sehr leid aber
wir haben halt auch termine wir sind
auch nur menschen und wir richten unser
leben nicht noch youtube sondern youtube
nach unserem leben und ich finde das ist
ein ganz schönes zitat um das hier zu
beenden das war die folge bleiben spaß
ja und zwar das heutige thema soll so
ein bisschen so sein so das
enttäuschendste weihnacht was wir je
hatten
was ich je hatte es wahrlich aufgabe mit
mich bezogen aber ich beziehe mich nicht
dabei ist die kür
sie sind doch alle kranken richtig
heftig enttäuschenden weihnachten hatte
ich eigentlich noch nicht auch kommen
jetzt nach halter ganz hinten einfach
ein richtig heftig enttäuschendes
weihnachten hatte ich noch nicht ich
hatte bisher noch eins wo ich gedacht
hat so da hatte ich auch keine richtigen
wünsche es an weihnachten da war war ich
einfach das war vor zwei oder drei
jahren da hatte ich einfach schon davor
mir irgendwie den neuen ds geholt oder
irgendwie sowas und den ich vor zwei
drei vier jahren da war ich 13 bin den
neuen ds geholt oder voll stolz drauf
und dann zu weihnachten dachte ich oh je
ich habe schon den neuen der ist das
kriegt er wohl zwei nachbarn habe ich
ein fast nichts bekommen irgendwie ich
weiß nicht und war auch verständlich
dass ich nichts bekommen wir zum
nachhinein aber ich habe mich halt in
dem moment so richtig richtig
durchgeführt weil ich hab mich richtig
auf weihnachten gefreut das war damals
die motivation beziehungsweise die
freude für weihnachten das sind ja immer
mehr mit der dauer mit der lebensdauer
mit dem alter und meine lippe ist total
trocken deswegen manchmal so damit
irgendwie weil sich das in touristen
drin und das ist mega trocken alles
wegen erkältungen und kälte und schnee
und alles wenn man dann mal täglich mein
fahrrad durch wird jetzt natürlich dorf
profit honda die ganzen kühe hinter ich
könnte ich hätte eigentlich alle fahren
können und mitnehmen können und darum
sind coole berg jetzt links im bild aber
egal licht tötet jetzt einfach erst mal
wissen was zu fressen
28 fleisch hat das richtig gut und
gleich geht die sonne unter richtig
schlecht ich hoffe jetzt einfach durch
das sind ja alles die begeisterung sinkt
ja mit der lebensdauer mit der älter man
wird desto weniger kann man sich für
feste begeistern ständig also für
geburtstag oder irgendwie sowas sagt
nein ich hab schon wieder geburtstag ich
werde noch mehr eltern und deswegen bin
ich eigentlich bin ich froh dass ich so
ein kleines kind bin bin ich klein aber
ich bin froh dass ich noch ein kind bin
mehr oder weniger mit 18 ist wenn auch
kein kind mehr aber ich bin froh dass
ich mittlerweile dass ich zurzeit mich
wenigstens noch so viele bzw fühlen kann
weil ich finde dass diese begeisterung
für weihnachten habe ich nicht verloren
gehen sollte weil weihnachten winter
finde ich ist für mich eigentlich
genauso schön wie sommer finde ich so
was natürlich geil da es war man kann
mit freunden am strand gehen und mehr
scheiße baut man nicht man kann darf man
kann sich mit freunden trifft man kann
volleyball fußball spielen man kann
lange draußen bleiben ohne dass es um 4
uhr schon dunkel wird so wie es
mittlerweile im dezember der fall ist
ich muss jetzt nicht irgendwie nach
hause kommen bevor es jetzt irgendwie
mega nacht wird und es wird hell grad
schon über nacht und ich weiß noch gar
nicht ich müsste doch eigentlich schon
nach hause kommen oder ich das jetzt
irgendwie stärke oder so weil ich würde
sagen dann esse ich jetzt die band
schnell schon mal ein bisschen ja ich
glaube ich erst mal ein bisschen ich
wenn ich musste ihm jetzt was es nicht
muss irgendwie gesund nach hause kommen
so setzt durch dass ich deswegen zu viel
davon schon zu verschwenden
ich werde ich mein leben irgendwie
aufbaut ja also das war halt so
ich bin froh dass ich als noch so ein
kind bin und das war halt wirklich nur
noch das thema zurückzukommen das waren
weihnachten wo ich mir wirklich so
gesagt haben man alter das war echt doof
weil ich war mit seiner vorfreude dass
weihnachten gegangen so gefreut wie
geschenke zu bekommen und man hat sich
halt damals so darüber gefreut dann
irgendwie geschenkt zu bekommen und
ja es war halt einfach fast nix also ich
hab dem buch bekommen t shirt das war es
dann auch
und ja keine ahnung fand ich halt damals
nicht so schön aber im nachhinein kann
ich eigentlich nachvollziehen ich meine
eltern sind auch nur menschen sind jetzt
keine maschinen die ihr ziel irgendwie
geschenke produzieren und alles mögliche
dies ist dieses hohe gras in 1.7
hinzugefügt wurde sollte man im schnee
um dann auch dementsprechend anpassen
sowie das gras und nicht so grün lassen
finde ich hier war doch irgendwo unser
haus oder alte als ob das noch
weitermachen
da war doch da irgendwo wieder sprinten
geil dauern ist sogar schon
ausgeleuchtet ich wette das war da
irgendwo her sonst bin ich aber gar
nicht verwirrt eigentlich müsste das
hier irgendwo sein
genau hier sogar da hinter dem berg
nicht behindert aufspielende bitterlich
gefroren
eigentlich muss ich nur das tun was da
hinten grad anzeigen
bislang laufen und ich bin schmeckt
wieder im haus vorbeigelaufen das kann
natürlich auch sein erbe eigentlich ja
nicht hier ausgeleuchtet dass das lama
das ausgeleuchtet irgendwo und danach
sein vor allem weil hier auch das eis
tun region ist
oder verstehe ich mich gerade immens das
ist unser bio ich hoffe einfach hier so
dann kann ich mehr sprinten und ich
wohne ja eigentlich direkt am meisten
region
das kann ich auch nicht sagen ich kann
man von da hinten entweder ich wohne da
oder da aber ich glaube ehrlich gesagt
nicht dass ich hier wohne irgendwie ist
mir noch ein bisschen fremd hier ja
keiner auch nur das war halt so das
schlimmste weihnachten was ich bisher je
hatte wo ich halt mich echt ein bisschen
doof gefühl hab irgendwie wo ich mir
dann gedacht oh mann ich hab mich so
darauf gefreut und ich find auch heuer
doch wir wollen hier auch com ag hat das
schön gemacht das ja schön eigentlich
gedreht
der dort eine menge gefahren
natürlich hat sich die ganzen suppen
alleine gemacht
dieser brei dpa da dieser psa ich finde
wir sollten das hochhaus auch ich
endlich mal ein bisschen schöner machen
möchte auch eigentlich auch noch mal ein
bisschen was jetzt hier
das kann man noch so alles blüht nicht
tun wenn die items einfach lava baguette
und croissant so acht das wollte ich
hier noch ärgern so ja das war somit
mein schönstes weihnachten beim sonst
gab es keine schlimmen weihnachten nur
wo ich vorher noch mal drauf kommen
wollte war die sache dass diese sache
dass man weihnachten nur als geschenk
vergabe ansieht ich denke das ist auch
man sollte da es ist meine lippe
unglaublich rothner das ist so krank das
tut richtig weh tut mir leid dass das
bisschen doof aussieht aber egal
und zwar glaube ich dass das auch mit
der zeit alles vergeht und zwar ist es
halt so macht man die anderen denken
sich sogar kommen wir treffen jetzt hier
und opi und das ist so schön und wir
haben uns lange nicht mehr gesehen
kinder freut euch mal kinder jérôme
europa das ist für uns also wir kennen
diese person nicht so richtig wir kennen
die seitdem wir lieben aber wir haben
wir den es jetzt keinen speziellen drei
bilder reden mit denen ich nicht so viel
wie mit unseren eltern die kümmern sich
nicht so richtig um uns also klar wenn
man das kriegt man essen trinken die
freuen sich wenn man kommt doch logisch
man mir müssen wir selbst überlegen was
wäre wenn ihre kinder hätten und diese
kinder hätten schon kindern das ist
quasi der einzige kontakt von euch
irgendwie nochmal zu kleinkindern also
ich finds auf jeden fall auch später
wenn ich jemand bin finde ich auch
richtig cool wenn meine neffen am besten
den kompletten tag bei mir während
meines neffen
braucht keine ahnung wie heißen wenn
ihre wenn man europa ist die kinder von
den kindern enkeln henkel bräuchte total
verhindert ich glaube es in enkel enkel
ich würde mich auch freuen wenn die
enkel lassen das muss man sich mal
selbst überlegen ich denke immer so ja
kommen eltern sagen sie ja kommt es mal
zu fahren und wir dann immer so ich und
meine geschwister nicht so
also es ist wirklich so ich hab mir das
mal durch den kopf gehen lassen weil ich
habe auch immer ein schlechtes gewissen
wenn ich dann zu sagen ich komme ich nun
kommt nicht mit
meine mutter sagt dann irgendwie so ja
okay kommt nicht alleine freuen die sich
bestimmt ein schlechtes gewissen weil
ich weiß genau wenn später bei mir ist
dann würde ich mich auch freuen und da
werden die kinder auch nein sagen aber
ich glaube ich ich werde den kindern
nicht übernehmen weil ich weiss auch
damals dass das ist halt bei mir damals
genauso war genauso wie letztens wir
wollten heute feiern gehen habe ich in
kontakt
ja genau beim kontakt ich das ja gezeigt
dass sich mit chris feiern war und die
halt wir sind halt beide noch 17
und wir sind halt man kommt mit 17 da
nicht rein unter 18 aus man hat eine
aufsichtsperson die leute von euch die
gerne feiern gewissen das bestimmt dann
mit mutti zettel ausbildung alles
mögliche und da war dann wirklich ganz
viele personen sagen ein vater nehme ich
bin schon voll
also ich hab schon die liste voll und da
war wirklich eine person die hat es alex
an der stelle großen arber 19
der zum ersten mal welche mit
reingenommen und der meinte zu uns er
macht das nicht weil er irgendwie von
uns was irgendwie geld möchte oder
irgend sowas halt gesagt ja wir können
ja irgendwie fünf euro gehen wir das
hier macht oder so sondern er meinte
einfach
er weiß genau dass es bei ihm damals
genauso war vor zwei jahren selber ihr
einkommen selber das problem dass
18-jährige gesucht hat und er versteht
uns einfach vollkommen und deswegen dem
1300 er möchte nach einfach nur ein
bierchen mit uns trinken und das fand
ich echt so geil und solche leute solche
aktionen finde ich irgendwie
symbolisieren oh mein gott ich dachte
schon der baum tötet mich alter da kommt
einfach ein behinderter zombie meine
fresse also mit aufs thema
zurückzukommen ich finde solche aktionen
sind einfach wie komme ich jetzt hoch
solche aktionen sind einfach
symbolisieren nicht für weihnachten
aber ob spielen da bin habe ich gefragt
wo ist die baumkrone brauche ich mich
ihr geld komplett falsche oder sehr
schön macht er schon lehre ab gefällt
solche aktion finde ich sie nicht jetzt
unbedingt symbolisieren für weihnachten
natürlich kann man sagen das
symbolisiert weihnachten natürlich auch
jetzt bestimmt nicht gemacht weil das
ich dachte weihnacht nächstenliebe
blabla sondern einfach weil korrekter
typ war und das ist echt mega cool
gewesen von ihm dass er uns da einfach
so mit reingenommen hat also gruß an die
ich alex falls du das irgendwie sehen
solltest bisschen korrekter typ und ich
finde das auch mit den großeltern später
dass man irgendwann später wird man das
verstehen und ich werde es auch
verstehen wenn meine kinder wenn meine
enkel heißt es glaube ich später nicht
so gern zu mir möchten weil die haben
halt keinen direkten draht zu mir
aus sicht der supercopa und die wird
meine videos von damals gucken keine
ahnung ich weiß es nicht ich werde nach
vorne später zu meinen kindern so zu
sein wie die freunde von meinen kindern
und zudem sind diese untereinander sind
weil meine eltern sind zwar keine
beleidigung blabla aber keine ahnung ich
versuche halt mir natürlich zu sein um
mich an der zeit anzupassen ob ich das
hinkriege weiß nicht das ist ja das ziel
von jedem elternteil irgendwie cool zu
sein und sonst will ich sagen ich wollte
endlich folge war 13 minuten belasten
aber das wird thema war ich einfach
beenden weil ich das halt schon länger
mal sagen wollte wie es eure meinung
dazu schreibt in die kommentare gibt
eine bewertung aber egal ob positiv oder
negativ aufgefallen hat oder nicht
natürlich sagen sie uns in der nächsten
folge christmas kraft morgen bei komme
wieder wo wir beide dann zusammen sind
in den chao